Robert starts off this hour in Miami hey
Robert welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
Thank You Davis a pleasure to be on I
really appreciate you take my call well
thank you sir how can we help my wife
and I who are calling an open enrollment
and I'm a big believer in your teachings
as far as the HSA plaque she wants to do
the PPO now my thing is this whether
you're in an HSA or a PPO you have to
hit the deductible folks before they
cover a hundred percent more
specifically I mean you need to get to I
guess the max out-of-pocket
now for the PPO the
the deductible is lower for the HSA the
deductible is a little higher but the
max out-of-pocket is a little bit lower
for the HSA mm-hmm where do you go with
the HSA or the PPO you still have to pay
that deductible and get to the max
out-of-pocket level now my wife and I
recently had a baby and they paid really
a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
worth of bills but we didn't hit the max
out-of-pocket and now she's on this she
has this concept in our mind that we
still need to go with the PPO because
the insurance recently just paid so much
for our child what I don't understand
how they did that if we didn't hit the
max out of pocket I can't get her to
switch to the HSA which I know it's
going to give us tax benefits at the end
of the year based on the fact we're just
happening with our child mm-hmm okay so
she doesn't want to switch because she
feels like she owes the money since they
just paid claims no no no she feels that
it's more beneficial well it's not I
don't I don't really care how you feel
this is a math thing you don't need
feelings I see the calculator yeah and
so it's a it's a calculator both of them
will cover your family and the only
question is when you run out different
scenarios which one's going to cost your
family more now here are the here are
the two things that you can look at and
this is the way the math will work if
your family is
very healthy and doesn't go to the
doctor much at all then the HSA is a
lower premium higher deductible and
you're not going the doctor much at all
and so it's going to be cheaper okay the
HSA is also going to be cheaper because
it has a very very low out-of-pocket
once you make the deductible most of
them cover a hundred percent d'azyr's I
think it's ten percent coinsurance okay
up until what you know what your
stopping until up until the max out of
pocket is seventy three hundred on the
HSA the stuff to pull it's four thousand
as opposed to the PPO would where the
doctor borders yeah they max out of
pocket be a half million usually no yeah
yeah I could be I mean what's your max
out of pocket on your PPO on the PPO max
out of pocket at 9 grand okay so there's
a two thousand dollar difference so just
run the scenarios out under what
circumstances and is that 80/20 on the
PPO on the PPO I think yeah I'm pretty
sure it's 80/20 yeah okay so twenty
thousand dollars would get you of
expenses would make the HSA anything
above twenty thousand dollars would be
cheaper anything under the deductibles
would be cheaper the only time the PPO
is going to be the best deal
mathematically and you run these numbers
now but this is the way it'll work is is
where see the two thousand dollar
difference with your max out-of-pocket
you got to make that up at 10 percent or
20 percent depending on with this PPO or
HSA you got to run those right okay and
that takes twenty thousand dollars to do
that to get that covered because you've
got a ten percent difference so you get
two thousand dollars on ten percent so
that's 20 grand okay so anything above
20 grand the the HSA is going to be
cheaper anything under 20 grand down to
the deductible the PPO is going to be
cheaper so where are you going to have
the most of your events happen between
five and twenty thousand above twenty
thousand or less than twenty thousand if
you have a sick child that's got chronic
stuff and you're going to be spending a
bunch of time in the hospital the HSA is
going to be cheaper
because everything after 20,000 you're
making money on the HSA because it's at
10% rather than at 20 on the copay you
see how did that like I've got a friend
no it's a math thing if she refuses to
discuss this based on math then we can't
have a discussion about it that's like
we have a different issue now we have a
marriage issue right okay because it's
not a feeling thing because both of you
want your family to be covered the only
question is mathematically which is the
cheaper okay I have a friend who has a
child with chronic illness his HSA has
saved him a bazillion dollars because he
has a 50 100 dollar deductible and a
hundred percent is paid after that he
meets his deductible the first month of
every year so if you're not sick at all
or you're sick all the time the HSA is
cheaper it's if you're in the middle
that the PPO is cheaper if you just want
to go the doctor and have a $20 copay
and go the doctor all the time and
you're gonna live over at the
pediatrician three times a month and you
pay the $20 copay the PPO is probably
going to come out better but like we
hardly we knock on wood Ramsey's have
not spent a lot of time in hospitals or
doctors we've been really really blessed
with health and so the HSA has saved me
a bazillion dollars because the premium
is lower on it than it is on the PPO how
much lowers your premium see the premium
is 174 on the PPO but what I would want
to do is to just put the wife's mind at
ease I would put that same 170 for every
pay period into the HSA so we can
eventually get up to the point where we
have the mass deductible I mean the max
out-of-pocket that's that's a different
discussion we're all we're talking about
here is the insurance portion not the
savings portion so the HSA the premium
is how much that's whatever we want to I
mean I don't know not with nothing going
into savings what is the health
insurance premium like we're switching
what Rose was this year went on high
single HSA I put in forty four dollars
every pay period we're switching to a
probably could be technically listen you
can't compare the savings element the
savings element is an independent
variable mathematically the savings
element I'm going to do with so you've
got to find out your premium if the
premium is 175 on 1 and the premium is a
hundred on the other you have a $75
savings a month and that's what your and
then you can offset that against the
other now your if your deductible is a
little bit higher you yes you can use
the savings portion of the HSA and yes
you do get a tax deduction and yes those
do add benefits to the math but really
it's an independent discussion because
her concern right now because she's got
a sick baby is do we have the money do
we have an insurance coverage that's
going to take care of my family and do
we have it most efficiently
mathematically and so I don't need to
appease her I'm not trying to appease
her I want to have an honest
intellectual mathematical discussion
insurance - insurance and then she says
okay I see that but I sure would feel
better if we throw another hundred bucks
into the HSA cool will do that to a
but we've got to make the decision as a
family based on math because that's all
this is there's not one of these it's
better quality than the other both of
them are gonna get you good doctors both
of them are gonna tear your family